BORIS MASIS: Hi.
I'm outside a cafe
at the Google office
in Mountain View, California.
And we're about to see
how guerrilla usability
testing with as
few as five users
can help you find up to
85% of the core usability
problems in your app.
Come on, let's go take a look.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thank you for stopping by.
I'm working with a client
on a mobile application.
And in a minute, I'll
show you the application
and I'll ask you some
questions about it.
It'll take about 10 minutes.
As you go through
the application,
I want you to think
aloud to voice
whatever you're thinking or
feeling as you look through it.
Please be honest.
This is a test of the
application not of you.
Time out!
Guerrilla usability
testing is a lot of fun
and it's one of the
most effective tools
you have to improve the quality
of your app or a website.
In fact, it doesn't matter
if it's an app, a website,
a remote control, or a door.
Usability simply
means that people
can use the thing for
its intended purpose.
And here's one
fun and simple way
to conduct guerrilla
usability testing.
Go to a fairly popular cafe.
Ask people to test
your app for 10 minutes
and then give them a
small treat as a thanks.
It's a great way
to spend an hour.
OK, time in.
The great news is that you
only need to talk to five users
to find 85% of the core
usability problems.
The most important
usability problems
are easy to spot for people
who are new to your application
and difficult for you to spot
because you no longer have
fresh eyes.
You're too close to
the product to know
how real people perceive
it for the first time.
Jakob Nielsen is a
usability testing pioneer
who led extensive research to
arrive at the magic five users
number.
It turns out that
you learn a lot
from the first person
you talk to you,
a little less from the
next, and so forth.
After the fifth user,
you're wasting your time
by observing the same findings
repeatedly but not learning
much new.
You can use our
ready-made template
to customize your survey and
print out a sign for the cafe.
Next, decide who will go.
One or two people is
the perfect number.
You don't want to have
more than three people
because it may make your
tester feel uncomfortable.
Everyone involved
in your product
should go at some point.
This includes your designer,
developer, product manager,
executive, customer
service people, et cetera.
You'll want to
choose a nice reward
to give your testers like
a gift card to the cafe
or buy them a drink or desert.
People who are alone
are easy to ask.
And remember, after five
people, you're done.
The think aloud method
is critical for getting
inside the user's head.
It means asking the user to
speak out loud everything they
are thinking.
For example, they should
be saying things like hmm,
this looks like a news app.
I wonder how I can get it
to show me the sports news.
Maybe if I tap
here, that's where
I think it might let
me select the category.
Oh that loaded pretty
slowly, et cetera.
Be sure to take good
notes of what people say.
Some clear patterns will emerge
from the feedback you get.
Back home, you can fix
these usability problems.
And what's critical is
that you then come back
to the cafe to validate
that users no longer face
these issues.
All right, well, I
think we're done.
So now that we're finished, do
you have any questions for me?
MALE SPEAKER: No, I
thought it was interesting.
I hope the feedback is helpful.
BORIS MASIS: Thank you so much.
And now it's your turn.
You now have a new
tool in your belt
to make your app
even more awesome.
Go on and try this
out in the real world.
You can customize our
template and questionnaire
to suit your app.
I'm Boris Masis with the Google
Developer Relations team.
Thanks for watching.